pop it down so if you were earning like
say 50 000 a year couldn't you be that
same person amongst your peers 100
that's what I'm trying to say 100 you
could and also also you have to money
doesn't make you a top G no no money's
an amplifier so that's that's the first
thing about money money amplifies men
can make money money does not make men
if you're a door can you get rich you're
a rich dork if you're a gene you get
rich you're a top G right so that's the
first thing about money and I agree with
you but
and this is the Baseline and once again
when I say these things I'm not looking
to be attacked from a misogynist I'm
just commenting on how I view the world
and how I see things traditionally a man
primarily gives his attention to a
female to get sex and she gives him sex
back to get the attention that's the
swap right so if I'm a dude and I want
sex from a girl I give her attention I
talk to her I hang out with her I spend
time with her eventually I get to sex
that's how it works but the higher value
you are as a man the more valuable your
attention is the more valuable your time
is the less you have to give it's like
potency right